موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم تظاهر الاف
الاسرائيليين ضد الرئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتانياهو اغلق الطرق مطالبين باستقالته
وهاجمت اعداد منهم الحواجز الامنيه على
الطرق المؤديه الى منزله في القدس المحتله
في الاثناء حاصر محتجون مقر الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي وذلك بعد ساعات من اقاله
نتنياهو وزير الدفاع على خلفيه ازمه
التعديلات القضائيه بعد رفضه دعم
التعديلات
وقالت وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه ان الجيش
رفع حاله التاهب ودفع بتعزيزات بعد فقدان
السيطره داخل اسرائيل ودعا قاده في ائتلاف
نتنياهو الحاكم للتراجع عن تعديلات قضائيه
تحصنه من المساءله في متاهمه زعماء
المعارضه بتجاوز كل الخطوط الحمراء وحذروا
من انهيار الدوله وقد اعلنت النقابات
العماليه عزمها شن اضراب وتعطيل الاقتصاد
وقد اعلن القنصل الاسرائيلي في نيويورك
استقالته احتجاجا على اقاله وزير الدفاع
في ردود الفعل الدوليه قال متحدث باسم
البيت الابيض ان الولايات المتحده تشعر
بقلق بالغ رذاء الاحداث في اسرائيل وتحث
القاده الاسرائيليين على التوصل الى تسويه
في اقرب وقت ممكن من جهاته حذر مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي من تاثير الازمه على
الجيش الاسرائيلي
دعت وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الى عقد
اجتماع استثنائي لمجلس الامن لمناقشه
التصريحات الروسيه بشان نيه موسكو نشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا ووصفت
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه الخطوه الروسيه
بالاستفزازيه
قال متحدث باسم حلف الناتو ان خطاب روسيا
عن الاسلحه النوويه خطير وغير مسؤول واضاف
ان الحلف متيقظ ويراقب الموقف بدوره قال
مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيفوريل ان استضافه بيلاروسيا اسلحه
نوويه الروسيه تعني تهديدا للامن الاوروبي
مشيرا الى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي على
استعداد للرد بفرض مزيد من العقوبات
بدوره قال البيت الابيض انه لا توجد
مؤشرات لدى واشنطن على ان روسيا نقلت
اسلحه نوويه الى بيلاروسيا وقد جدد
البنتاجون الالتزام بالدفاع الجماعي في
اطار حلف الناتو وكرر البنتاغون في بيان
موقف الناتو من انه لا وجود لاي مؤشرات
لاستعداد روسيا الاستقلاب لاستخدام اسلحه
نوويه
ودافع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن
قرار نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا واتهم بوتين حلف الناتو بالتوسع
شرق اسيا
سقطت مسيره اوكرانيه محمله بمتفجرات في
مدينه كيريفيسك على بعد نحو 200 كيلومتر
جنوبي موسكو واعلنت خدمه الطوارئ عن اصابه
ثلاثه اشخاص جراء الانفجار واعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انها تمكنت من تعطيل نظام
الملاحه في المسيره قبل محاولتها استهداف
مدينه تولا الروسيه
اعلنت ميليشيا فاجنر انها سيطرت على مصنع
تتحصن فيه قوات اوكرانيه في باخموت في
غضون ذلك قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
انها تصدت لاكثر من 50 هجوما روسيا في
اتجاهات عند ابرزها ليمان وباخمت وخاركيف
ختام موجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]